Oh
[Music]
all right welcome back to Gd 50 this is
lecture eight today we're gonna be
diving into the world of unity for the
first time which I'm excited about I'm
gonna be kind of a whirlwind tour but
we'll try to cover as much as possible
transitioning away from 2d and away from
Lua and love 2d into 3d and c-sharp in
the context of unity so today we'll be
talking about helicopter game 3d so a
helicopter game is a 2-d game that was
really famous in the 2000s it was a web
game I was sponsoring a bunch of
websites addicting games calm still has
it on there and a few other websites
have it it was a flash game but I
remember playing it alot it was the old
precursor to flappy bird which was
mentioned on the Wikipedia page there's
a reference to it there and this is sort
of what the gameplay looked like it was
very similar to flappy bird a little bit
different in that instead of trying to
avoid pipes you're in a cave and you're
trying to avoid the ceiling and the
bottom the ground of the level and there
were these little obstacles that would
spawn in the middle as well so you'd
have to navigate that but it was the
same exact mechanic the sort of like
click to go up and then when you didn't
click your helicopter would just sort of
sink down via gravity today we'll be
talking about a bunch of brand new
topics things like unity first and
foremost the sort of ecosystem with
which we'll be doing a lot of the things
we'll be doing c-sharp is the primary
language we'll be using so we're gonna
take a step away from dynamic languages
and move towards statically typed
languages languages like C sharp and
Java and the like blender is a program
we'll look at briefly today just because
in the context of 3d development you're
going to want to have a tool that will
let you create models and so the 3d
software that I like to advocate for the
most especially for folks that are just
starting out is blender because it's
free and open source and it has much the
same feature set as any commercial
software like 3d studio max and cinema
4d and the like we'll talk about what
components are entities and components
how they relate in this model that unity
has adopted for all of its programming
components are little pieces of behavior
that you can then sort of combine to
form a whole that will then drive the
behavior of whatever object in your
scene you want rather than having to
customize its behavior via a you know a
long chain of inheritance and
instantiation
colliders and triggers are important in
3d at 2d but today we'll be talking
about colliders and triggers things like
the helicopter colliding with coins and
buildings and other planes that are
flying each of those has to have a
Collider and certain things have to be
considered triggers in order to trigger
certain behavior with other entities
prefabs and spawning so prefabs is a
huge concept in unity so prefabs are
basically prefabricated objects that you
can customize as you want to lay them
out in the editor rather than having to
necessarily code all the details and
then you can instantiate them in the
actual scene via code programmatically
in a way that fits the model you're
striving for texture scrolling is
something we'll look at briefly because
it's the way that we accomplish the
infinite sort of scrolling aesthetic or
behavior and we'll look at how we can do
that in a different way than we've done
before using UV coordinates and
specifically looking at materials and
modifying certain attributes of those
materials and lastly to tie everything
together as we've done before we'll look
at audio things like audio listeners and
audio sources with the differences
between them and how to add them easily
to our game project but first a demo if
there would be anybody willing to come
up and take a look and play the 3d
helicopter game that I put together be
awesome hey buddy Steven awesome thank
you so much let me go ahead and actually
get it
so I've pre-built it so let me go ahead
and so the nice thing about unity is it
exports to multiple platforms and right
out of the gate you can get just a I
didn't put an icon for it but you can
create just a native application very
easily and so whenever you're ready go
ahead and hit play and up-and-down will
move your helicopter so this is the 3d
hollow copter game and I don't think we
have sound alive but there should be
audiio oh I might have actually here we
go there we go that's my bad so there's
music playing there's sound effects so
notice that we have a 3d model it's as
if this is what's called a 2.5 D game so
even though everything is in 3d the
models and so forth
the actual
maxi's upon which were bound are just
too we're just bound to the believe the
X and the y could be the Z and the X I
don't recall offhand but we're bound to
just simply two axes of movement but all
the models as we can see via the camera
are in 3d including our helicopter so we
have a few things going on we have
skyscrapers that are scrolling by we
have coins that are also going by at the
same speed as the skyscrapers we have a
background that is infinitely scrolling
we have off course our helicopter which
has a rotating set of blades and when we
collide with a coin notice that we get a
little it might be hard to see in house
but we have a little particle effect
that plays there's airplanes that are
flying up top so we're instantiated us
to provide another layer of obstacle and
if we collide with a airplane notice
that we get D spawned and then we
trigger another particle effect to
imitate an explosion and then notice we
also have a couple of other elements we
have a GUI we have two GUI elements a
sort of coin total at the top right and
then a game over bit here in the middle
of the screen which only shows up once
we have once we have died and the
exposure explosive behavior if you want
to collide with a building you'll see
that it also triggers when you collide
with the building so there's two things
looking for these explosions the the
airplanes up top and the buildings below
those are our two obstacles but when we
collide with the coins we should
increment our coin total and then
display a different particle effect and
then this goes on ad infinitum you can
press space to restart so we have
keyboard input that's you know based on
what we press different things happen
and so that's effectively the the demo
that I put together today so thanks
Steven appreciate you coming for demo so
that's the 3d helicopter game it's got
most of the same mechanics as the the
version the web version from before I
would say maybe even more features just
to illustrate a few new concepts but
that's effectively what we're going with
today we're just a pretty simple flappy
bird esque differently themed game based
on the same principles you know fly
forever avoid obstacles and in this case
even get little collectibles and so
notice that they're also to effectively
two states in our game which are just a
playing state and then again
/ state the two are almost effectively
the same the only real difference is
that one doesn't have the helicopter
present and displays a different GUI
element in the middle of the screen if
you haven't downloaded unity already
there's two links here so the top link
is just the sort of catch-all download
link and then the second link is the
beta link so we're actually using the
beta in this course because unity has
started transitioning away from a
numerical system for their releases and
is now going yearly for their releases
so the last long-term release candidate
was 2017 s version but now that we're
almost halfway through 2018 the newest
beta is the 2018 version it has a bunch
of new features so go ahead and check
that out and it's everything's been well
tested and runs very well very smoothly
on Windows and Mac with the new beta so
what is unity so unity so the difference
between what we've done so far and what
we're doing today is now we're actually
using a full-fledged sort of game engine
the system it's got a built-in editor
and all this awesome cool functionality
that we really didn't get with love 2d
before what we were doing before was
using a framework and just implementing
everything purely in code and as we'll
see today everything that you want to do
that's customizable effectively is or
can be done via code but there are a lot
of more efficient and more user-friendly
ways to accomplish the same thing which
we'll take a look at so unity has a
tremendous market share right now I
forget I think in 2016 it had like 43%
of all games released were done in unity
I don't know what the what the current
numbers are I couldn't find them but
there are other engines that are also
very well used unreal being among them
and unreal actually may have more market
share now because of games like
fortnight and because it's been sort of
improved a lot over the last couple of
years and really marketed well but Godot
CryEngine there are a lot of game
engines that are similar to this that
provide you this all-encompassing sort
of way of dealing with your games scene
and with all your game data but unity is
a very easy engine to start getting used
to and cranking things out and being
productive with without the tremendous
learning curve that some of the other
engines like unreal might have unreal
does have a more user-friendly way of
doing things but if you want to get down
into the
you know the nitty-gritty with unreal
you're coding and kind of semi arcane
C++ so for folks who aren't used to it
and what used to 3d game development can
be kind of a large board to get on to
the nice thing about unity aside from
the fact that it's fairly easy to get
started with is that it's free and you
can use it completely with all of its
features until you start making over a
hundred thousand dollars in gross
revenue using we're releasing unity
products and then there are other tiers
the next tier above that is if you start
making two hundred thousand and you get
new features with these other tiers but
if you want to just start up a new
company and use unity and take something
to market completely free to do so and
once you get you know over a hundred
thousand dollars it's a good problem to
have it's not necessarily too much to
ask to you know start paying unity to
use it as a means of getting onto the
market in the first place and especially
in mobile and VR unity is sort of like
the forefront it's got even higher
percentage I think that's like 60
something or 70 percent market share on
mobile and then VR from the beginning
it's been very it's marketed itself very
strong towards the use of VR and will
actually use VR in the next lecture and
the way at which we will accomplish all
of the programmatic aspect of this
getting things actually implemented in
code is via C sharp which is very
different than what we've used so far
which we've used Lua which is a dynamic
scripting language very much like Java
Script will actually be using so c-sharp
is very similar to Java and which things
actually have types and so here's a
couple of screenshots of what the unity
editor looks like so the nice thing
about the unity editor actually which we
can see right off the gate here is
that's very customizable so on the top
that's sort of the default view you know
you have a bottom panel that shows you
all your resources all your assets
things like scripts and shaders and
models and textures and sounds
you have a nice file browser there on
the left hand side which allows you to
easily navigate your project you don't
have to go looking through your Windows
or Mac computer you know using your
finder or whatnot or your file explorer
and actually look through all your files
you get a nice view there so that you
you stay integrated within the unity
ecosystem right there on the right hand
side you can see all the behavior for
whatever objects you might have in your
scene you get a nice big scene view so
rather than
having to run your game live and you
know look at the behavior that way you
can actually see in advance what your
scene looks like and analyze your game
objects that way and their appearances
and you know whatever you want to do
with them and lay them out perfectly
rather than have to programmatically
figure things out and on the left-hand
side there you can see a full list of
all the game objects and then on the
bottom right screenshot you can see that
the editor is heavily customizable so
you can lay things out however you want
to to fit your style of development I
often like to have a panel on top which
shows me my scene view but then have a
panel right below that that shows me the
game view so if I'm actually running a
game and seeing it happen live I can
also see it in the scene and sort of
rotate around in sort of this god mode
that you would get with he can get in a
lot of games and actually analyze and
see things that way to analyze their
behavior frame by frame even if I want
to in a way that's not possible with
however I might have coded the camera in
the actual game itself so C sharp so as
anybody in here used a static language
or familiar with statically typed
languages versus dynamically typed
languages you should do you Mack
so what languages have you guys use just
a curiosity Steve
Java C C++ Donnie C++ okay so this to
you guys this will be pretty it's pretty
similar so c-sharp is very similar to
Java almost looks identical at first
glance there are some features that are
different but it's sort of Microsoft's
initiative was Microsoft's initiative to
sort of compete with Java it's a
Microsoft language first and foremost
but there are ways to run c-sharp code
on other platforms primarily with use of
what's called mono so mono is an open
source implementation of what's called
the CLR the common language runtime
which is how Microsoft allows several of
its languages like F sharp and C sharp
and C plus visual C++ Visual Basic they
all sort of compile this intermediary
format like how Java compiles to
bytecode and you can run any of those
languages code the their version of the
bytecode with the CLR and that the mono
what mono is and what unit
relies on to allow its use across
multiple operating systems is a CLR
that's not just a window specific it
actually runs on Mac and on Linux
machines as well and you'll actually see
evidence of its existence via the
nomenclature used for monobehaviour
so within unity there's this thing
called a mono behavior which we'll take
a look at from the beginning actually
unity was developed for Mac platforms
exclusively but in 2012 or 2011 they
ended up making it usable across all
major desktop operating systems but
c-sharp suffice to say very similar Java
will look at its syntax but it's
different from Lua in that with Lua you
could just say oh you know x equals 10
or object equals and then create a table
with whatever you want c-sharp is a lot
less flexible in this sense in that you
have to actually tell it in advance what
each data type is that you're trying to
make so you can't just create a table or
a integer you actually have to say int
my int or x equals and then 10 and then
semicolon so there's also more syntax to
be conscious of and so really quickly I
can show you just what some c-sharp
looks like we'll take a look at this
again going forward but as you can see
here we have public so here's that
that's another thing about c-sharp and
Java if you're familiar with Java
there's their object-oriented
programming languages and as such there
are objects that are public and private
and you have access specifiers for
different variables and classes that'll
tell other variables and classes whether
or not they can communicate effectively
so public class just means anybody
effectively anybody can see this class
other classes can see this but then you
have C if I have one of these that has a
private variable I know there's at least
one here we go
so private text text here for example so
first of all notice that these are our
variable declarations like we've seen
before
you know we're saying this is a variable
that I'm going to use in this case
public game object helicopter so I'm
just defining it or I'm declaring it I'm
not defining it it doesn't equal
anything
yet but I'm saying this is going to
exist right you can say equals something
and then define it on the same line but
in this case we are just declaring in
advance what different variables we're
going to need later on when we like for
example here we see in our start method
and we'll go over what all these methods
are and how they're relevant but we can
see here text equals and then we're
calling some function called get
component and then we have some funky
syntax here less than text and greater
than and then function call syntax two
parenthesis so we can see that there's a
lot more syntax but all of the same
principles still hold true it's still
much the same way to think about
programming it's just there's a little
bit more to stay conscious of and we
sort of trade off this dynamism for more
performance so that's ultimately what it
comes down to static versus dynamic
languages your trading flexibility for
performance in this case the c-sharp
obviously is a lot faster than Luo we
can do a lot more with it and actually
unity isn't itself programmed in c-sharp
unity itself is programmed in C++ but it
allows us to program any behavior that
we want to with c-sharp all right so
that's a look at c-sharp so we can see
also I was alluding to up here we have
our private public and we do things with
them and then depending on you know sort
of what we've declared public or private
these things also transfer into the
editor well see how all of that comes
together soon but suffice to say that's
a look at c-sharp what it looks like and
we'll use it and we'll get comfortable
with it but it's it's a little bit
different than what we've done this far
away from programming we'll take a very
brief look at what blender is so I have
it installed here and this isn't
required for the course I will provide
you with all the models and all the
assets that you need to get working but
this is what blender is so blender is a
it almost looks at first glance very
similar to unity it's the only
difference I mean well the big
difference is if this is meant to create
new assets and technically blender does
have a built in
game engine but it's not used for that
purpose very much but the sole purpose
that we would be using it in this course
would be just to create new 3d models so
as you can see here I can click on these
vertices and move them around and you
know I'm not a guru by any chance by any
stretch of the imagination when it comes
to blender but the helicopter and jet
and skyscrapers and those kind of simple
models I made all those in blender and
those are bundled with the project if
you want to take a look at how those are
implemented and you can download blender
at the I forget what the exact link is
actually let's take a look
blender.org and then yeah if you just go
down here download blender 2.79 looks
like the most recent version blender 2.8
I guess there it's in development but
there's nothing concrete about that on
the front page but yeah if you want to
model 3d assets and you're curious and
you want a free piece of really awesome
software can't recommend blender enough
but like I said not going to spend too
much time on it because that's not the
it's not something that will actually be
required in the course to implement 3d
models to create 3d models since I'll be
providing all of that to you in the
project and they github repo and so
here's a screenshot of basically what we
just saw
so the fundamental part of unity so
first of all let's take a look at the
unity editor so we can see here much of
what we saw in the screenshots but here
I'm live looking at my scene right I
have a helicopter I have this background
back here I have a camera that's right
here it's you can see that it's a camera
because it's got the little camera icon
but it's effectively just an invisible
game object it's not actually going to
be rendered to the screen ever and
notice that there are no skyscrapers no
coins no jets or anything like that
those are all instantiated dynamically
but this is the beginning of our scene
and it's all laid out in advance and we
can see here with this camera preview
which is kind of hard to see because
it's really small but here's a larger
view of what it looks like and there we
go we got a GUI element here we've got
coins here we have our helicopter but
all of this is sort of how it's a it's a
market difference from what we've gotten
used to which is you know pro
everything and sort of load it and oh
did I put this in the right position
no I didn't so I got a if I wanted to
come over here and just move the
helicopter a little bit which like that
whoops I just triggered its if you click
on something by the way it will play
it's any particle systems that are
associated with it so you can actually
get a preview for those as well but I
can easily just move it here to the
right or to the left before the game
actually starts and if I click on the
camera we can see it there it's a little
bit shifted to the left as opposed to
what it was before but if I just press
command Z a couple times take it back to
normal so game object is an important
concept so a game object is basically
everything in unity so the camera is a
game object the helicopter which is
right here is a game object everything
by the way that you want to see in your
scene in unity is on this left-hand
hierarchy right here so helicopter game
object there's got to be a light source
in a 3d scene in order for you to
actually see things so directional light
that's a game object background
skyscraper spawner we don't see it
anywhere but that's also a game object
it's just an invisible one a coin
spawner there's something called a
canvas which if we double-click that we
can see we have this obscenely large GUI
here that you know paradoxically isn't
on top of our scene unity does a very
interesting thing with it's all of its
GUI elements in that it maps its it
basically maps the the canvas to one
pixel being equal to one unity unit
which is usually equivalent to a meter
and it draws this in a different call a
different draw call than it draws all of
the like actual 3d stuff 3d all the
stuff that's down here basically in
world space so when you create a canvas
and you see it's gigantic
that's just unities way of doing GUI
it's it's strange but apparently they do
it for performance reasons because they
don't have to calculate like fractional
points of where the UI is supposed to be
in world space which can get really
small but that's the canvas is a game
object notice that helicopter has
children it's got blades a body and then
a blades Collider which actually could
have been part of just the blades object
canvas itself has two children coin text
and game over and those are the text on
the top right and game over in the
center so those are just two game those
are just two text objects which are
labels that we can just populate with
whatever text data we want the event
system is an object that's part of the
that just gets added to your scene
automatically when you add a canvas
airplane spawner explosion particles and
explosion sound so we have all these
different objects they're all part of
our scene and they all do different
things but at the core they're just game
objects that's the sort of core like the
bottom type yes correct
so the question was since we are
maintaining a consistent position with
the I'm going to transfer all in there
we go the nice thing about unity two is
if you right-click you can use WASD to
move around the scene which is super
easy and convenient but the helicopter
here stays in one spot and the camera
always stays in one spot forever so do
we move the text or do we move the
background image like we do in flappy
bird our love to the implementation of
flappy bird where we reset its position
and the answer is I will play it right
now in scene view and let you decide
that for yourself so let's go to window
I'm going to go to layouts so I like the
2x3 like I said before so you can see
the scene and the game running live at
the same time I'm going to move my
camera in the scene so that I'm looking
at this kind of from back here and then
I'm going to play the game
and so
here's where we I'm just gonna hold it
still so what do we think is happening
does it look like that it doesn't look
like our thing is moving or is it
staying still
it is think still any guesses as to how
we're achieving this changing the
texture we are scrolling it's texture so
when you take a texture and apply it to
a 3d surface you basically tell it where
you map the texture coordinates to the
3d coordinates of the object that you
want to render it's called UV mapping
they call it UV because usually when
you're dealing with 3d objects you have
your X Y Z and then you want to think of
your texture kind of separately from the
3d object so you use UV instead of XY
since I already have XYZ allocated for
your 3d object and so by shifting the
there's an basically there's there's an
offset part of the texture then the
material that holds the texture there's
an offset field that will sort of
reposition the UV mapping of that
texture on to the 3d surface and when
you offset it it will just sort of wrap
itself around if that makes any sense
so what we do is we can you actually
show you in the code where this is this
is this is going to be mentioned at the
end of the lecture but the we have the
scrolling background component here and
there's this thing on each material
called a texture offset which basically
shifts the UV mapping of your texture to
your 3d object and so by setting that
texture offset to some value offset
which is very similar to what we've done
before
notice that offset is just scroll speed
times time time time in this case and I
don't mean to overwhelm with necessary
all the details here but the bigger
picture is that we're taking time the
amount of time since the beginning of
the game is started and we have some
scroll speed that we've predetermined
and we can just scroll the texture
offset here we're just placing it here
at the X so this new vector to offset 0
just think of these two as an x and y a
Veck
two vector three vectors are just
combinations of numbers so one two three
four however many you want a vector to
offset and zero so we don't want to
scroll on the y-axis we just want to
scroll left to right so we're gonna
apply no texture offset to our y-axis
but we want to apply texture offset to
our x-axis so that's what they're offset
there is and I included that also here
notice there's a bump map texture offset
there's no bump map actually on our
texture so a bump map is effectively I
can maybe find a good Google image for
it if you're not familiar with a bump
map go in here I'm gonna hope that
there's no shady images on Google Images
but a bump map can we see it well it's
kind of hard to tell but in a lot of 3d
games you'll see you'll see kind of like
bumpiness and shininess on surfaces and
that's accomplished the majority of the
time using bump mapping because
obviously if you were to model like
every single tiny little bump or a model
and a surface it would get extremely
difficult to render like large objects
because I mean that's you're looking at
thousands of polygons for a surface that
was this actually this detailed in a
game so what you do is you take what's
called a bump map and the bump map gets
during lighting it'll effectively though
it'll effectively skew the surface
normals of a 3d mesh so effectively it
will pretend as if your 3d mesh has a
bunch of bumps in it for the lighting
only for the lighting and so when it
gets lit it looks as if it's you know
bumpy but you're still dealing with a
completely flat completely simple cubic
mesh in this case or whatever mesh you
want and so you can the long story short
here if you wanted to include a bump map
on whatever surface you want to scroll
or if you want to edit the bump map this
is here just because you can also
manipulate the bump map texture offset
it's an included
[Music]
filled in a material so any questions as
to sort of how this works at large but
we still have a lot to cover before we
go into like a lot of the specifics but
conceptually does it do we understand
how this sort of works okay cool so
let's go back to the slides right so we
were talking about game objects so all
of those things that we saw before
we're just game objects so let's go back
to the default layout and then we can
look back at our scene so this our scene
all of those things were all of our game
objects those are ultimately containers
I talked about this in a prior lecture
but this is the beginning of an entity
component system in which case these
game objects are our entities that's
there at the entity class container
class for what drives behavior and the
thing that allows us to actually get
interesting behavior out of this sort of
abstraction is the use of components and
we'll talk about that
so components are all of the things on
the right hand side by default of the
unity editor editor so if we're looking
at our camera for example and we take a
look at all these things on the right we
can see that we have something called
transform we have something called a
camera a gooey layer deprecated so
that's by default it was imported from a
prior version of unity so this you could
actually delete this a flare layer which
we're not using an audio listener I
believe that comes with all cameras by
default though in case you do want to
use it an audio listener and an audio
source so all of these different pieces
are our components they're what drive
the behavior of this game object so if
we can create just a brand new empty
game object
oppai created as a child we can create a
brand new empty game object here right
it's just a game object in our scene and
it's right where our mouse is right well
it's right here and it does it does
nothing it has it has one component and
that component is the transform anybody
know what anybody guess what I transform
is
yeah yes it is the position rotation and
scale of a game object something that
was before you know put into six fields
or in this case nine fields potentially
or maybe three fields with sub shot with
children is now an object that we can
modify at will so well it's a it's a
component that we can modify at will so
if I if I do this notice I'm just
scrolling the X it's just moving that
transform which is just the position of
that object and unity knows to look at
that transform component and render our
object based upon what it where its
transform lies rather than us having to
manually set all these things which we
still can do in the code we can just
modify them in the unity editor directly
by a graphical interface it's a just a
interesting helpful layer of abstraction
so a transform is a component a camera
in this case is just a component we can
attach this to anything we want to and
it becomes a camera and then we can set
it to be either the default camera or
not the camera has a bunch of different
things and I'd I can't claim to know all
of the fields of every object in unity
because there's just a tremendous number
of things but clear fact clear flags
background calling masks all these
things that are relevant to sort of how
the camera does its job they're all
things that we have complete access to
here in the unity editor we don't even
need to touch code really for a lot of
things and interesting fun thing we can
take a look at is if we go to layout to
go back to two by three and take a look
at our our game again so we have our
camera currently looking at the screen
here right it's just always in one spot
and it has a way of projecting the scene
it's either it can do one of two things
it can be orthographic projection or
sorry perspective projection or
orthographic projection does anybody
know what the difference is between the
two are these visually so perspective
projection what that does is it models
how real cameras real lens is the human
eye etc behave in real life things
distort a little bit
and so you see things depending on where
you're looking at them they look wider
or skewed and not like completely
geometrical like you would if you were
just to like draw them at a certain
distance things have vanishing points
etc orthographic things look a lot
different so notice instantly so we can
see here perspective it doesn't really
change a whole lot
visually with our helicopter things do
change a little bit with the background
because the view angle is different
between the two the perspective and the
orthographic camera but if we look at if
we make this a little bit larger so I'm
gonna increase the size like that and I
play one thing we'll notice what it
what's the first thing that folks are
noticing you can actually see the
difference between the top and the
bottom look how in particularly I'll put
your attention towards the buildings how
do the buildings differ you can't see
the side anymore their angle there they
the lens sort of a lens sort of curves a
bit and so I'm not entirely familiar
with all the math involved but at the
end of the day what it boils down to is
with a perspective camera you can
actually gauge things as distance
relative to each other a little bit
better with a pro or thoa graphic camera
everything is completely flat and no
matter how far away from something from
you it is on the axis that's completely
perpendicular to you it's gonna look the
exact same
so these buildings are always gonna look
the exact same no matter how far away
they are no matter which position they
are because everything has just looked
at completely flat and everything is the
few matrix is calculated in a different
way and so just with a simple button URL
you can change sort of how your game
looks completely you've probably seen a
lot of games I believe Crossy Road does
everything with a orthographic camera
versus a perspective camera it has a
very distinctive look
especially once you sort of skew things
a little bit but the that's just one
thing that you can change just without
having to touch a single line of code
how your game will looks via just the
cam
as implementation let's take things back
to how it was and there's a lot of
things like the field of view so if you
want to see more of the game world so
things like in quake and other shooters
you can change this view usually in your
menu settings just you can see more
around you and it starts to look this
sort of look like a fisheye lens a
little bit depending on how you do it
and that's just more distortion of the
perspective projection yeah all these
things they all have I don't know it
necessarily what every single one of
them does just because it's there's just
a lot involved and generally you don't
have to mess with it too much dependent
alta merely depends on what you try to
accomplish in your game and you'll end
up finding specific areas of the editor
and specific areas of the codebase and
documentation that you dive deeply into
but that is this essentially is what a
component affords you the ability to do
when you create a component and you
attach to a game object you can easily
not only combine different things to
sort of create this emergent new
behavior and combination of behaviors
for your game objects but unity allows
you via different ways of programming
the components to modify them depending
on how customizable you want them to be
in the editor itself so you don't have
to touch any of this in code you can
just go into the editor and quickly whip
things up because your the way that
you've modeled all your components and
so we see other things like the audio
listener and audio listener is something
that will literally listen for audio and
play it back like a microphone to the
game player and then an audio source is
an actual source of audio so it'll play
that audio at the location of whatever
that game object is so we've combined
all these things and now we have a
camera that is perspect it's projecting
everything with perspective perspective
projection and it's an audio listener so
it's gonna listen for audio in our scene
and it's gonna play it but it's also
going to play an audio source and listen
to itself and that's just that's just
the beginning we have a whole bunch of
other components here which I mean we
can take a look just really quickly so
the
directional light has a light component
and so will light you can do all kinds
of things you can make it a spotlight
directional light point light all these
look a little bit differently you can
make it have a specific color so if we
wanted to mean maybe if you wanted like
a really dark scene you could have like
a dark light or you can even like
emulate dawn or dusk with like an orange
light sort of that's sort of how you'd
go about doing that
you can bake your lighting which means
that you just pre-compute it so that you
don't have to render it in real time
when you actually play it on Hardware
all these a lot of different things a
lot of different settings we don't have
time to start to go into all of them but
you know looking through all of these
you can see all these game objects are
just combinations of these components
and that combination of component the
combinations of components are
responsible for the behavior that we get
in our game at the that's the ultimate
essence of what unity is and how it does
what it does and to illustrate the
difference we've talked about this
before this is an inheritance chain
we're creature inherits from our monster
and hurts from creature which then goes
to goblin goblin chief elite goblin
chief in unity you could create a game
object right and then give it a creature
component a goblin component a patrol
component right so maybe you want
different things to patrol you can have
it like a in unity be kind of
complicated but you could create
basically a pathway and then have your
entity follow that pathway at a specific
time and then depending on how you've
programmed it you could specify all
these different characteristics in the
editor so you could just say on the
editor okay I want you to go patrol from
this range to this range and I want you
to do it with this length of time pause
for this long right and then you can
give that to anything in your scene you
could you could make a camera patrol if
you wanted to and then have that be like
demo code for the beginning of your game
it's the flexibility is just insane
elite component right if you want maybe
certain enemies or certain objects if
they're elite maybe they shine bright
maybe they drop more experience or
something
a chief component maybe has better
weaponry than like a non chief component
and then a toxic component maybe is like
an enemy that when it dies it like
sprays like toxic gas or toxic liquid
all over the place
but the flexibility is there you can you
can ascribe any
opponent to any object to get any sort
of behavior that you want to it's on you
of course to implement all these
components right you're not gonna get
all these for free you're gonna get a
lot for free unity gives you a ton of
components really good components but of
you know your ultimate ly gonna need to
program your game logic and so you'll
have to implement all these things Elite
Goblin what it means to be all these
things but thankfully it's not terribly
painful the way at which we go about
doing all of this and by the way are
there any questions so far
as to how like unities model works the
difference between composition versus
inheritance anything we've talked about
this far alright the way at which we
actually go about making our own
components which is probably what you'll
spend the most of your time doing at
least in the beginning when you're
bootstrapping your game is excuse me
programming what's called a mono
behavior and so we talked about mono
before so mono is the sort of open
source implementation of the CLR and
monobehaviour I imagine I tried to look
this up and see where it derives from I
imagine it's because it was originally a
Mac exclusive project unity and so
because everything was implemented in
mono and because this is the way it's
scripted monobehaviour became the name
but a mono behavior is what a component
is they are effectively one in the same
the difference being that a mono
behavior is how it's in code in c-sharp
if you want to program something to be a
component that you can then attach to a
game object it needs to be inherited
from monobehaviour things like so if we
go to like coins bonner here so the coin
spawner has and you can see the
difference between like what's built
into unity and what's your own via it'll
say script here so in this case I have a
coin spawner object right it's just an
empty object at least in terms of what
it displays it's got a transform which
is irrelevant it could be literally
anywhere on our entire entire scene the
only difference between this
and the empty game object that we saw
before is that it has a coin spawner and
this coin spawner has a this thing here
it's just a it's a all components that
you add will have the script field here
just to show you that that's the script
that it's inherits getting its code
behavior from but also we have this
field here called prefabs which has a
size of 1 because it's actually
calculated based on how many elements
the list that it's responsible for has
and we have one element as it says here
and it's got a coin prefab which is here
this coin prief and notice that I
clicked on it it took me right to it in
my assets and so prefabs and all of that
what that means and how to get that all
working we'll talk about that but a coin
spawner script has to exist in our code
base before we can actually add it to
any company game objects right so if I
go into my so in my project I do have a
usually you have assets a folder called
assets in your unity project and then I
I typically create a resources folder
it's not mandatory that you do so but
just for organization I'll create a
resources and then I'll have a bunch of
folders for all sorts of different
things like we've done before where in
the love 2d project at the parent level
you have like a fonts a music or sounds
a and then like a source directory and
here in this case we have fonts
materials models all the different
assets that we will need in our game but
also a scripts folder and all the
c-sharp scripts here whoops all the
c-sharp scripts here that we'll use
amongst all of our components all of our
game objects and so you could easily
just go to any of these rather than have
to go into your operating system open up
a new you know window and find your file
and navigate through all the files that
unity generates for you which can be
kind of a pain you can just double click
on like a coin script for example and
it'll open in your default editor and so
one thing that I'll just mention here is
if you go to your community preferences
Mac its unity and then preferences you
can go to external tools so by default
starting in 2018 unity is transitioning
away from its prior IDE which was called
monodevelop which was a good IDE there
transitioning away from that and they're
making it focused on Visual Studio as
the default IDE I don't use Visual
Studio
I like vs code so what I did was and
what you can do is you can choose your
external script editor here if you
prefer a different script editor like
Adam or vs code or sublime text and then
just browse for it on your file system
whether you're on a Windows Linux or Mac
machine and then you can easily just
choose which file you want in this case
I chose vs code and so that effect that
that has is whenever I double-click on a
script within unity it'll actually open
the IDE or text editor that I have
assigned to it in unities preferences
and so here is the coin component that I
have created for this example and notice
that it's a every component first of all
is a class and actually everything
effectively in c-sharp just as in java
is a class it's a public class and
notice that it's I call it coin and I
got this : and then monobehaviour so
this : anybody know anybody take guess
what the colon means tiny extends yes it
extends or inherits uh from
monobehaviour so anytime you have a
component that you want to create you
want to add it to unity and allow you
allow you to see it in the editor and
allow you to actually drive behavior of
an object you need to inherit from
monobehaviour like it says here my vs
code since I have the extension for Omni
sharp it'll actually tell me model
behavior is the base class from which
every unity script derives there's a
couple things here so notice that we
have a few methods so void start avoid
update and void on trigger enter so
anybody take a guess as to what ignoring
ontriggerenter does anybody have a guess
as to what's starting to update do
yeah so I say one more time exactly it'd
be just like just like we did before
when we created objects in our love 2d
projects where we had an init function
as assigned to every class and an update
function assigned to every class and we
would call those ourselves every
monobehaviour can have a start method in
this case it's empty because every time
you create a new script via the unity
editor it will automatically first of
all it will automatically create a brand
new file for you so if we want to let's
just say I want to create a new script
so if I'm in the unity editor and I go
to my assets I right-click create and
then I want to create a new C sharp
script it'll create it there I can say
maybe I want this to be I don't know
test component right so this should have
the effect of when I open it in my vs
code this test component this was
auto-generated for us we didn't have to
write any of this boilerplate
but every monobehaviour or every script
that you create rather by default by
default is a mono behavior which now
distribut does not have to be you could
create a class of your own that maybe
you call behind the scenes or maybe it
just represents a data structure or
something but by default anytime you
create a new script in an in unity it'll
save you the hassle of typing out all
this stuff by hand and it will give you
an empty start method and an empty empty
update method and so like Tony said the
start method gets called as soon as the
object that it's assigned to gets
instantiated as soon as well as soon as
this component gets instantiated rather
which usually often is the case that it
gets instantiated at the same time as a
game object not always you can create
game objects our components on the fly
but this start method will get called
anything that you put in here will get
called right away and then this update
method unity will every frame go through
every component on every live game
object and we'll call the code that's
contained within this update function
and you don't have to call this anyway
yourself just by assigning this
component to something in your scene
assigning the component to a game object
in your scene you get the sort of update
and start and all this other
functionality given to you for free and
mono behaviors are actually much more
complex than just start and start and
update so if you go to monobehaviour
cuz in time we go to monobehaviour
here we can see that by the way I want
to shout out unities documentation ooh
he has amazing documentation Doc's
unity3d calm it will you'll go through
pretty much everything you possibly
could ever want with um every object
implemented in unity and quite a good
detail with a lot of examples but here
we can see just in the description it'll
tell us the monobehaviour will get start
update fixed update late update on GUI
all these functions called for us
assuming that they're implemented and
you don't have to implement them if you
don't want to if they're not implemented
they just won't happen if there's no
start method then that means there's no
start logic for this component so it
doesn't need to execute if there's no
update maybe just needs to start at the
very beginning but never update after
that don't implement update and update
will not be called all of these are
optional that's just a small chunk of
monobehaviour though because you also
have messages so messages are functions
that you override as you can see there's
a whole lot of them and all of these
messages get called depending on certain
things that happen in the game scene so
on trigger enter for example if our
object is a trigger and we enter it then
the behavior will get called in that
function which will allow us to do
things like if our helicopter enters a
building we can call the helicopters
explode method which is literally what
we do in this project thanks to this
function and all we need to all we
really need to do is just a couple lines
of code it's very simple on post render
on pre render all these different things
are called at different times you can
look into all of these if you want to
just by clicking on them and
looking out their documentation late
update is called after all update
functions have been called this can be
relevant for physics certain physics
calculations but there's a whole lot of
different things you can do not you
don't necessarily need to do a lot of
things yourself if unity provides you
with the function that gives you the
effect that you're looking for and so if
you're curious monobehaviour and then
the docs at large this is just all the
documentation just an insane amount of
documentation and that's just in the
classes there's all these other little
side areas as well and so that's that's
sort of what monobehaviour is it's a
component it gets a lot of these
functions called for you
you don't have to implement them but if
you do you get a lot of functionality
for free basically any questions as to
what a monobehaviour is how it works and
so forth or any of the syntax we've seen
thus far for creating a monobehaviour
all right and so here in our coin for
example which we were looking at before
notice that I'm referencing something
called a transformed transformed
opposition dot X is less than negative
25 destroy a game object if this is the
coin what do we think that this is
accomplishing yep so the transform
recall was our object that our component
that encapsulates our rotation scale in
position so we can just say if transform
position dot X is less than negative 25
destroy game object because we're
spawning the coins dynamically when they
get off screen just like we did with the
pipes if you remember and I had a
screenshot actually in that slide that
sort of showcase what that looked like
we can see that exact thing alive here
if I go to layouts 2 by 3 and we play
the game again and then I'll just die at
some point but if I if we do this right
we're seeing our scene live so we're
following this yep see how the coin
won-soon is the building and the plane
and the coins I'll get to this point
this is negative 25
in unity units not in pixels everything
in unity is based on unity units which
by default one is equal to one meter as
opposed to we've been stuff are using
just pixels but pixels aren't viable in
3d but that's effectively what that
component does it's checking on our in
our update function void update if
transformed opposition dot X less than
negative 25 and notice that we don't
actually have to declare transform
anywhere which is interesting and that's
because monobehaviour by default gives
you access to its game objects transform
just by default that's just something
you get for free and then notice game
object we don't also don't have a
declared game object anywhere because by
default we have access to game object
it's the game object that this script
belongs to that this component belongs
to this would be the actual that so the
interesting thing about classes is you
don't have to explicitly say this
because if you had like int my number
equals 10 and you just say my number the
difference between like Lua and like
c-sharp and Java is that my number it'll
already know what my number is this is
my number it'll know it's this objects
you don't have to do that sort of a nice
little thing to save you a little bit of
time yeah cuz I you can then just say my
number plus equals 10 another nice thing
about c-sharp by the way which we didn't
get in Lua you can do compound
assignment operators so you can do plus
equals minus equals x equals that's one
of my pet peeves I have with oh and
notice that also the nice thing about
the fact that I have omni sharp it'll
underline and this is this is just a
trade up most IDE s honestly so you get
this with a lot of places but it'll tell
you my number is not assigned and with
the underlining and also just by
hovering over the name my number does
not exist in the current context
but I can just say my number and then
it's gone a little bit more that we have
to worry about you know and a little bit
less so we have to learn a worry about
little give-and-take but still I think
overall c-sharp is gonna be a lot more
syntax heavy you do have to worry about
things like braces and semicolons and
you know putting everything in kind of
like a boilerplate and then you know
obviously type declaration and return
type declaration it can be a little bit
more than we've gotten used to so far
but it's honestly not too bad just given
the that you can use ID ease first of
all the fact that you're statically
typing everything you can detect a lot
more errors in advance if you're trying
to do something with some type that
you're not supposed to do like some
function accept some object of some type
but you're passing in some other object
you'll catch that in advance and so
that's a really nice thing but yeah it's
it's kind of a give it's it is a give
and take and also I des will give you
like I said a lot of the functionality a
lot of the autocomplete that makes a lot
of this more sustainable and that's not
to say of course that Lua and left you
don't have their own IDE like zero brain
studio is popular from what I understand
haven't used it yet but particularly
when you venture into Java and c-sharp
and compiled languages statically which
is having those features it does save
you a lot more time relatively speaking
than when you're in a dynamic language
so yeah that's a model that's what mono
behaviors are every component of our
game effectively has like the helicopter
has its own script a heli controller the
coin has its own script the coin spawn
or the skyscraper spawn or the
skyscraper they all have their own
scripts that drive their game behavior
but they also have scripts and
components that are part of unity core
as well including colliders and triggers
so if I am looking in unity so I'm gonna
go to the and this will actually be the
last thing we look at before we take a
break but if I'm in unity and
I'm gonna go back to my default layout
just cuz it's a little cramped on a 720p
go to my helicopter
helicopters got a couple pieces to it so
let's actually go to where I can see it
here so one of the awesome things I love
about unity is it gives you a lot of
this editor magic this editor sort of
sugar it shows you visually where a lot
of the things are in your game world so
the green rectangle is anybody note
those are or I can guess yep pit boxes
exactly these are colliders so the
blades doesn't have a Collider that
blades Collider is actually separate the
Box Collider here is this Collider right
here and so a Collider is literally just
something that collides with something
else and you can set it to be a trigger
or not if it's a trigger then it
actually won't it won't trigger the on
trigger callback function that we've
briefly saw earlier so the things that
you want to activate triggers you should
make those not triggers and then
triggers you just all you have to do is
just click this little trigger button so
what a trigger is is just a region that
you've determined or some object that
you've determined should cause behavior
when it gets triggered so in this case
I've assigned actually we could go to
I'll just play it but the airplanes a
trigger has a trigger right the every
building has a well every building all
of these things have colliders rather
whether their triggers are not the
helicopter its blades and its body
there are two colliders two boxes the
coins all have colliders the skyscrapers
will have colliders and the airplanes
have colliders the difference is that on
by the way another cool thing
it's easy to get very sidetracked just
because there's so many cool things to
talk about you can pause the game while
it's running
so it's paused right now but it's in the
exact state that I left it so there's
three coins there I got my helicopter
there I can freely go about the scene I
can analyze things I can actually modify
this in real time so I can change its
rotation if I want to probably don't
want to do that but I could if I want to
I can change the position right so I can
move it left to right like that and
notice that I actually have just a body
selected so that the blades are kind of
separate I don't even know what kind of
crazy stuff would happen if I just like
messed with this and just let it run I
haven't tested at that crazily but
you're allowed to step through okay it
looks like they both just go yeah oh
yeah because they're so they parented to
the helicopter object so they're both
gonna align they're both gonna move at
the exact same rate regardless of how
far away far apart they are the
individual objects but you can just step
through your game's execution frame by
frame and get a sense of if you're
trying to pinpoint like a bug maybe
that's position based or something
that's kind of tricky and just haven't
been able to find exactly what's going
on you can look through all of the you
can look through your whole scene and
all of the fields of every object in
real time just by a not in real time but
in step time just by stepping through
this button here assuming that you're in
pause mode and then just looking at all
the components here on the right side
because those will also update all these
fields will update any time you perform
any changes in the actual scene so super
helpful for debugging I know I've used
it a bunch and then if I start again or
if I stop it
the nice thing is any of the changes
that you make while it's running to your
object they don't get applied when you
actually go back to the game so notice
that I with the the two pieces I sort of
separated them and then I stopped the
game and ended up going right back to
where it was in the very beginning so
all this gets it just basically saves
like a snapshot you can do whatever you
want doing your game and then come back
to it and it'll all get reverted back to
where it was yeah
oh yes
so yeah tonight just basically echo what
I just said which was if you make
changes in your in your game while it's
running and you're trying to maybe tweak
them such that it's perfect
when you're actually done they don't get
saved so you have to actually make a
conscious effort to remember what you've
done how you've changed different fields
to fix any bugs if they do exist but it
is yeah something that can be
disheartening or frustrating if you
finally fix something and then you
forget what it is you changed and then
you have to mess with it a whole bunch
so remember all the changes you make if
they're pertinent to your actual games
execution and the the debugging of your
game and then there's also a console as
well which is nice if you want to sort
of output things sort of like JavaScript
style in the web you can do console dot
log you know the same thing with a debug
call here in unity I don't have any of
those calls in the actual game but it is
something that we'll look at going
forward and it is something that can be
very helpful if you want to measure
something or output something that you
can't necessarily look at in the
inspector in the case of this game most
of anything that we want to take a look
at is visible inspector but if you have
an algorithm maybe you have a generator
that's not visual maybe you're like a
like a level generator and you want to
like make sure that you're the data
structure representing your level is
generating things properly you can
output everything maybe by hash marks or
something in your console and actually
see it that way when you're running the
code rather than having to run the
actual game and look through it that way
some some things just are hard to model
in the editor and still need console
output so that's the console is there to
sort of help you and so debug log is the
function I believe that you need to see
all that stuff write colliders and
triggers so we had a little bit of a
tangent there but the helicopter is
comprised of these three things but the
blades Collider should have ultimately
been merged with the with the blades
object here but we can think of it as
the blades on the body the reason
they're separated those two reasons
they're separated one is
well one core reason they're separated
is they're just different sizes so the
blades are longer than the body and so
we have for that reason to separate
colliders so we're looking at the
helicopter here we can see that the
collider for the blades extends a little
bit farther than the body we don't want
to create a box Collider for the entire
helicopter because a box Collider that's
like right that goes out here for
example might not be super fair if we
were just coming right over a building
and our and our body kind of like it
maybe the buildings right here and we
just miss it like we don't want that to
be collided with so sometimes you'll
need to combine colliders to accomplish
the collision detection behavior looking
at the nice thing about box colliders
which we're using here is that they're
not very expensive because they're just
boxes it's easy to compute 3d box
collision with other things that are 3d
boxes so and that's actually a sort of a
topic in its own is taking a complicated
model or object and then breaking it
down not in terms of what it looks like
to be collided with but how you can
simplify the collision detection of
something like a character by just
modeling its arms its body its legs as
like cylinders or boxes rather than
complicated geometry you usually don't
want to do pure geometry collision for
anything because that gets really
expensive you want to try and aim for
simple shapes to be your colliders and
unity gives you a lot of simple shapes
by default if we look at like for
example in our helicopter if wanted to
add a component which by the way you can
easily do here just in the component
inspector if you're looking at the
bottom right there's an add component
button so you can add any of the
components that you've written and also
the components that unity gives you by
default so if we look up by Collider we
can see there's a lot of different
colliders that unity gives us for free
polygon Collider mesh Collider box
Collider capsule Collider I try and
strive for boxes as much as I can
Spears aren't bad fears are usually
fairly easy to calculate as well but
boxes are the easiest capsules are
pretty easy to a lot of players will be
sort of capsule colliders because care
have rounded heads so emulating the
collision for their head with a capsule
sort of makes more sense and we'll look
at that actually next week when we use a
first-person component that we can get
for free the default Collider for it is
a capsule so but the blades are the yeah
the blades and the body both have their
own Collider they're not triggers but if
we look at our prefabs which will we'll
take a look at what a prefab is shortly
a skyscraper has a box Collider which is
a trigger as we can see here and the
coin is a trigger and the airplane is a
trigger so these things all trigger they
all accept other colliders that aren't
triggers and if it detects a collision
with a Collider that's not a trigger it
will call the ontriggerenter function
which we saw is something that you can
get with monobehaviour
yeah
you say okay give me a specific example
oh yeah so the question was can i
implement such that in it for example in
a pinball game if I have a ball that
collides with something and causes a
trigger to occur but also have it bounce
off of something and you would do that
with a rigidbody so you give it a
rigidbody
in this case we actually I actually gave
a rigidbody the helicopter because the
original goal of mine was to have it be
affected by gravity but I turned it out
that I actually liked it a little bit
better without gravity so this rigid
body isn't strictly necessary but it has
a gravity component that you can assign
to it that will actually then calculate
gravity and pull it down wherever the
you have a global gravity definition
that you that's in your unity settings
that will affect it that way and so what
you would do is you would give your your
ball a rigidbody and other things that
you want to bounce off of those would
also have sort of rigid bodies and they
could be static or kinematic or not
basically which we talked about before
kinematic can move but not affect other
but not be affected by other objects and
so the object that's a trigger you still
trigger code that does something so be a
pinball machine when it collides with
something and it's and it you know
triggers that thing it'll still do that
it'll still trigger that code so whether
that's increment your score or cause
something to flash a particle flash or
play a sound it'll do that in your
ontriggerenter but your rigidbody will
also perform its work and bounce off of
whatever it assuming that you don't
destroy it with that ontriggerenter
function it will bounce off of that
surface and behave in the way that you
are alluding to that make sense
all right cool so that's yeah so the all
these things have triggers the is
trigger flag that's I mean that's as
easy as we need it to be so we used to
give a box Collider and the nice thing
about box Collider too is if your mesh
is a box or square or rectangular it'll
usually just fit it perfectly to
whatever you're trying to assign it to
so in this case I remember adding the
box colliders for these skyscrapers it's
just because they're all rectangular or
cubical quadrille I don't know what's
the rectangular 3d I forget the term
what is it
rectangular prism yes since they're all
rectangular prisms the the box Collider
fits them it'll L scale the right way
when you have differently weird shaped
objects that can it'll just basically be
as big as it needs to be to completely
encapsulate it but like I said before
because the helicopter has got some
weird geometry if we were to do that it
would by default just be this entire box
here because this is the farthest it
goes out on this particular axis so we
want to combine meshes to produce the
collision sort of behavior that we're
looking for and the trigger enter bit is
relevant because if your game object is
a trigger right then once we collide
with that object we want and by default
when you do ontriggerenter it will look
for the collider on this object it's
going to take in a Collider other right
and what that is is the other Collider
the thing that's colliding with this
object with this coin so the helicopter
because it's the only other object in
our scene that has a non trigger
Collider ontriggerenter this is gonna be
a helicopter we can just say other dot
transform parent because our helicopter
has children which have the actual
colliders and our parent has the
helicopter controller component we're
gonna get component at the heli
controller so we're gonna go through our
that objects that other that collided
with us we're going to get its transform
pair
we're gonna do get component which is a
function that will just look through
it's all of its list of components we
specify which component we want using
this identifier here so of class heli
controller and the the these sort of
angular brackets are like of the generic
like the sort of generic type specifier
syntax which basically looks for it you
could pass in any type here effectively
and get component will look at whatever
type is in here and get the component of
that type specifically so you do have
some sort of type flexibility in c-sharp
but you have to go kind of the extra
mile and specify it and implement
functions that take generic arguments
like this which is similar to Java and C
C++ and other languages that do it that
way and then once we've gotten that
component of type heli controller with
this function call we execute pickup
coin which is a function that's part of
the heli controller any guesses as to
what pickup coin does
sorry and commence the coin counter
calls the coin to disappear well it
actually doesn't call the coin to
disappear because we do that here
destroy a game object game object is
gonna be this coin that's executing this
function does one more thing - do you
remember what happens when that when we
pick up a coin part of exactly the
particle effect it triggers a particle
effect we can go to the helic controller
class and take a look at that pick up
coin here coin total plus equals one get
component audio source play so it's a
little bit little bit weird so with
audio source you can have multiple audio
files so get components audio sources
what we need to actually get the audio
attached to this object and then at
index 0 because it's only gonna be one
one audio source anyway and then we just
call play so that'll play this the part
of the coin sound and then get component
because there's only gonna be one
particle system associated with this
helicopter object we're gonna get the
particle system object and then we just
gonna call play on that which will
actually trigger an emission one time of
its particles and so that's in a sort of
in a nutshell what colliders and
triggers are it's a lot of syntax that
wants because this kind of unity is kind
of really big but it's it's pretty
simple
just make sure that you give the right
shapes to your objects make the right
things triggers that you want to cause
behavior to happen when like non trigger
things touch them and then implement on
trigger enter with the behavior the game
logic that you need in the case of the
skyscraper for example if we look at the
skyscraper so I have a skyscraper
component here and then if I on trigger
enter here does it effectively does the
same thing that the airplane does which
is just go through the others transform
parent game object heli controller and
then call explode and to explode kind of
similar thing to what pick up coin does
and it triggers a particle effect but it
also destroys the helicopter and
it tweaks the gameovertext to turn on at
that point so any questions as to how
triggers work any of the syntax we've
talked about thus far I know that it's
kind of a lot it's kind of a fast tour
but moving right along alright oh and
here's a screenshot it took just to
illustrate the green lines the box and
then the orange is the actual mesh of
the of the helicopter so we're gonna
take a break and then when we get back
we're gonna talk about prefabs and
spawning them and dive a little bit
deeper into some of the other parts of
the project alright welcome back to GD
50 lecture 8 this is helicopter game 3d
so before the break we were talking
about colliders and triggers and also
just getting our hands used to using
mono behaviors and the editor and all
sorts of things but we haven't really
taken a look at prefabs which is a major
part of this game so the coins the
skyscrapers the airplanes those are all
prefabricated assets that we have sort
of gotten ready and ready for spawning
into our scene and we're gonna take a
look at how that actually works so
here's a list of in our editor view all
the different prefabs that we have so we
can see airplane blades and body our
prefabs the coin all the skyscrapers
there's three different kinds of
skyscrapers and then a helicopter the
helicopter itself we're not using as a
prefab because I've already created it
in the scene and it never gets
instantiated dynamically but we could
easily make it so because I have created
a prefab with the helicopter so when
you're looking when we're looking at the
scene here we noticed that we have just
a helicopter and we have the background
but there's no skyscrapers there's no
coins and there's no airplanes well we
do have our skyscraper spawner the coin
spawner and the airplane spawner and the
three of those are just empty game
objects but they have associated with
them
these spawner scripts and the spawner
scripts we've written ourselves and then
once we've written them we've just
simply add component here and then
chosen the appropriate spawner
and so what those do
if we look in our code actually and we
go for example to the airplane spotter
we have a start method we have an update
method notice that the update method
doesn't do anything paradoxically
because I mean the airplane spawner is
running over time we are spawning
airplanes over time but the way that we
do things over time sort of
asynchronously in unity is a little bit
different than anything that we've done
so far so this start method here we see
that we're calling this function called
start Co routine and that function takes
in a function called spawn airplanes and
so at a high level a Co routine is
effectively a function that yields
control every time it's called
so it'll it'll run and then rather than
return rather than go through its entire
body of code and then end or return some
value and have that just be the end of
it it'll actually yield when you call
the when you use the keyword yield and
depending on what you've done with that
yield it'll pause for some like the time
or do something for some length of time
rather than end that function call so
this spawn airplanes function here
notice that it has a while true and so
while true is not usually something that
you want in a game because that's just
going to lock your game forever but in
the case of a KO routine echo routine is
going to run but then it's going to
yield control back to whatever called it
for some like the time or you know
depending on how i've programmed it in
this case you can see here yield return
new waitforseconds random bout range
three tens anybody have an idea of what
that does yeah
it does it yields for three to ten
seconds and then richer and then
continues its execution that's exactly
right
you have a question you could do that
yeah I guess for the sake of
demonstrating prefabs and also it's a
little bit complicated to get into like
dynamic material setting and like
changing materials in code but yeah you
could effectively just create three
separate skyscraper one skyscraper with
one like base color and then dynamically
change its dynamically change its
material but also to illustrate having
multiple different prefabs assigned to
an object that you can then choose at
random to generate in the game scene
they might not necessarily be
skyscrapers that will have the exact
same color it could be like a goblin or
a orc or a troll or something and
they're all different prefabs that we've
created but you can put them in a list
and then dynamically choose which one we
want at random so a few different
reasons but yeah you know in a situation
where everything is just effectively
differentiated by a single color and a
material change you could dynamically
swap that as needed
so the this Co routine that we've
started this function that effectively
can pause itself even though it's being
called infinitely it's being called you
know this while true is in play it
yields control with this yield keyword
and what it does it it allows us to call
something over and over again but then
pause for some length of time right we
don't have to maintain a counter for
spawn time in here which we could do it
he likes float spawn time equals zero
right and then float spawn increment
equals like a thousand and then while
spawn time is less than spawn increment
or you know or we could say in update if
spawn increment or do we would do
spawning or spawn time plus equals time
dot Delta time first to get the length
of times path since the last frame and
then we would say if spawn time is
is greater than spawn increment
instantiate a new skyscraper or airplane
sorry and then set spawn increment or
spawn time back to zero and then just
rinse and repeat this over and over
again but co-routines take out this need
much like timer did for having anything
that you keep track of with a specific
timer you can do a whole bunch of
different things with coab routines one
of them in this case that we're doing is
just pausing for some length of time to
do something in this case we're we want
to wait for some time in between each
each call to our or in between each
instantiation of an airplane
so we'll just yield control back to our
game because we want to break out of
this wall true but we don't want to
break out of it and completely break out
of this function we want this to keep
going over and over again so we see here
this instantiate function is sort of
where the actual instantiation happens
and instantiate takes in a prefab so a
game object so in this case we have a
prefabs list here game object public
game object array called prefabs so this
can take in any number of prefabs that
we want it to we're going to return a
range between 0 and length and then also
we want it to spawn we give it a
position if I want to spawn in so
instantiate it takes in an object it
takes in a position and it takes in a
rotation in this case we want to give it
this position so it's a vector3 gets an
x y&z at 26 so off the right edge of the
screen 7 to 10 so kind of like within a
range of verticality up towards the top
and then at 11 on the z axis which is
aligned with our helicopter and the
skyscrapers and then this quaternion dot
Euler is a so 3d rotation is the math
behind it's pretty complex and I don't
know it well at all but quaternion Euler
allows us to think in degrees and
and actually perform a 3d rotation on
something fairly easily so if you want
to rotate something in 3d quaternion
Euler and negative 90 degrees on the
ability Z X Y in this case the way that
the default rotation of the airplane is
we want to set it to negative 90
negative 90 zero you could also set up
your prefab in a way such that you don't
need to pass this in you could do
quatrain and identity in that case but
this is just to illustrate how if you
want to rotate something in code how you
would do it
so quaternion Euler is the way that you
rotate something in 3d and so
instantiate global function that you can
call anywhere you want to as long as you
just give it a actual object or prefab
that it knows how to instantiate and
then wait for seconds another global
object which is a asynchronous object
that will allow us to yield for this
length of time we pass in the length of
time here it takes it in seconds because
wait for seconds and then as soon as
this length of time has passed it's
going to come back up here into this
while true instruction and then
instantiate again we don't have to keep
track of a timer or anything any weird
boilerplate we just have to call start
co-routine here and notice that we
explicitly have to call start co-routine
in order to to trigger a cutting
function and to do that it returns
what's called an eye enumerator and so a
lot of these details you don't need to
necessarily like know that low-level
details of I certainly don't like know
all the low-level details of everything
that happens in unity but just know if
you want asynchronous behavior your
function needs to return an eye
enumerator which c-sharp knows is an
asynchronous it's not asynchronous it's
a generator function which will yield
control at predetermined times and it
will manage it for you and to trigger it
you need to start co-routine which is a
function that unity has defined for you
so any questions sort of as to how this
works at a high level at least
yeah
so it's a yield takes in something and
you get a new to instantiate a new wait
for a second yeah you have to it's just
the way it the syntax is for yielding a
an object yield right it's returning
this to the yield instruction and the
yield instruction is then yielding that
so it is a little bit weird though but
you you only really have to like like
this is a common pattern that you'll see
and see oh just get used to it so and
honestly this is probably like one of
the more syntactically difficult things
about unity so I mean as soon as you
understand this pretty much anything
else is fairly it's fairly easy at that
point I would say this is one of the
weirder sides of because I mean in in
Lua I'd love to D and like those kinds
of environments it's a little bit easier
to do the sort of thing with as much
syntax c-sharp being a statically typed
environment to get the same behavior can
I have to go a little bit a little bit
further do things a little do things
their way
but that's ace that's getting
asynchronous behavior to work in c-sharp
and in unity typically yeah in order to
avoid sort of like messy state
management you will use co-routines
which are AI enumerators often with the
wait for seconds object and just make
sure to trigger them with start
co-routine and then call that function
as if it were an object just like that
and the behavior for the Airlines
airplane spawner the coin spawner and so
forth they're all fairly fairly similar
so start co-routine spawn coins and then
while true
so coins this row is just it spawns a
random number of coins vertically so you
can have one or you can maybe have a
couple and then for each of those
instantiate them at a random position on
the
on the y-axis here random negative 10 to
10 in this case quite ranting about
identity because we don't want to rotate
them any differently than there already
are which I alluded to before so
quaternion dot identity just means no
rotation applied to the object so
whatever its base rotation is as a
prefab so it'll have it'll be whatever
is when you see it in the editor and
when you create a new one that's it's
that's it's gonna be its default
rotation so basically the equivalent of
don't rotate this and buy anything and
then the same as we saw before yields a
new wait four seconds in this case one
two five so a little bit more frequently
than the airplane on average more coins
as the airplane I believe was one to ten
or three to ten so every three to ten
seconds and that's basically that and
then we start co-routine just like we
did before with the airplane spawner
and then lastly the skyscraper spawner
in this case we actually we only have
one coin prefab we only have one
airplane prefab but we have three
skyscraper prefabs and so the actual
random dot range here comes into play
because that's how we get you know the
different color skyscrapers spawning at
random and like I said before this can
be extrapolated to whatever sort of game
environment you want where you have
multiple types of objects that are more
complicated than just a color swap and
you want to choose them at random we're
doing all the same things that we did
before and also here we can see that
they have a random chance one in four so
25% chance of increasing the speed so
skyscraper spawner actually has and this
is relevant to the assignment a
skyscraper spawner has a float called
speed here which is by default ten and
this drives the speed they have the
scroll speed of the skyscrapers the
coins and the airplanes and so when we
call it static do we know what that
means
yeah yes so no matter how many
skyscraper spawner as we create only one
they're all going to share this field
speed and it's always gonna be equal to
the same amount across all instances so
a static means that it's part of the
class it belongs to a skyscraper spawn
or class it does not belong to a
skyscraper spawn or object and so we
don't ever really want to change that
ourselves in this game but the airplane
for example you know notice that in our
update function here if the transformed
opposition dot X is less than negative
25 we should destroy the airplane so
when it goes off screen we should
destroy it but if not then we want to
translate this object on the x-axis by
negative skyscraper spawn or dot speed
times two times time Delta time so we're
translating it on the x-axis and we're
using the skyscraper spawn at speed as
our core multiplier and then if we do
this if we look at coin same thing every
coin you notice that or I should ask
what is one sort of design consideration
if we're looking at this all these
components and let's say we're trying to
get as sort of decoupled as we can and
well-engineered as we can what's it
what's a consideration that we can
notice noticing that for example this
exists in coin and this exists in
airplane
so how could we better engineer this
notice that we have and and taking into
consideration this component model in
unity what could we do with for example
this well I'm thinking that because the
airplane and the coin though first of
all it wouldn't belong in the spawner
because the spawner is job is just to
spawn coins but the coins and the
airplanes they have their behavior right
they have their update behavior but they
are all doing kind of the same thing
which is scrolling to the left and then
despawning at negative 25 so a design
consideration here would be maybe we
have a scroll component right okay it's
it's like a scroll and destroy component
or just a scroll component with an
optional destroy flag and then we just
put this on anything that we want to
automatically scroll to the left screen
and de-spawn rather than having to code
this in every single class so if you're
ever looking through your code and
you're seeing for example this and this
being the exact same especially in unity
because of the way how flexible
components are try and think about how
you can make it into its own component
so you make it yourself so if we went
into here into our scripts pot thing and
it's made a new script and then we call
it like scrollable and then we double
click it it'll open up in our editor
that we've chosen in our preferences by
defaults gonna be Visual Studio with the
newer versions but now we have a new
scrollable behavior and then all we need
to do we would say if DUP's not that if
transformed uh once again I can't type
transform position X is less than
negative 25 destroy game object right
and so this is the exact same thing as
all that behavior that we saw before so
now we just we can take all of that out
of coin you take this out and we take
this out here and then just add to the
airplane and to the coin prefabs we just
add this new scrollable prefab and then
we'll take care of that
for us yeah so if we're going back to
unity so the question is how would you
add the prefab or out would you add the
component to the prefab so in our
prefabs note that we have airplane we
have coin and we have all the
skyscrapers so these are all prefabs oh
and I haven't actually detailed how to
create a prefab which I apologize for so
a prefab all you need to do is create an
object in your scene for example I did
with this helicopter so I'm gonna delete
the helicopter because this is just a
helicopter prefabs so I can actually
delete the helicopter from our scene but
if I take this helicopter here and then
I drag it in here notice that now we
have a prefab here so this is it's gonna
be we could take this helicopter out and
just add a new one like right there so
now I have two helicopters so that's
that's all a prefab is it's just a a
something that you've made in your scene
that you want to replicate they're
duplicate in the future ideally through
code and notice that it's showing here
in our our sort of hierarchy view but
obviously don't want that but that's how
you create a prefab is you find
something that you've sort of configured
in your game scene and then in your code
you're allowed to then instantiate that
prefab assuming that you've made that
prefab a a member of whatever you want
whatever class instantiate sit so in
this case the airplane spawner so notice
that we call instantiate here like we
saw before on line 24 but it's looking
at prefabs this sort of it's a it's a
list and it's looking at a random range
between 0 and the length of the prefabs
you have to declare public game object
list prefabs here and then once we do
that and we go our airplane spawner here
notice that we have this prefabs list
here so we actually get a editor view of
that code that data structure and we can
just add prefabs that we want to and if
we change the size the two then we can
add a second prefab or if we make the
size 10
then we can make put ten different
airplanes there but we only have one
airplane that I modeled so I'm just
gonna make it one but that's this this
is the same thing this game object list
is that same list only that that's the
view we have of it in the editor and
it's the same it's just like a different
way of looking at the data and that's
sort of the nice thing about unity is
that you can if you make any of your
fields public like this like public if I
did public int like some some number
right and I save that and I go back here
my airplane spawner should get a some
number right here and then I can just
set some number to whatever I want
doesn't do anything right now because
some number doesn't affect the script
but this is a nice way to take the
burden from you out of the code and like
expert you're not you know you're not
experimenting with code you're not
looking at you're not tweaking some
variable in your script some number ten
run me eight okay so number twelve run
it you can just assign it here in your
actual editor view and then just tweak
it as you want so I just scroll through
it I can I can start the game and I can
pause the game you have to make it
public exactly yep and so I can just do
this and then I should be able to it can
just change this now if I wanted to to
like sixty seven and so if set that
actually had some sort of effect on my
game world if my game relied on that
number being meaningful this would
update the scene and so you can make
whatever you can debug this way or you
can customize your components more this
way but it's just tremendous amount of
flexibility and so that's how we're
instantiating this sort of from this
list of prefabs it's a list of game
objects we've made it we've made it
explicit to unity the editors gonna know
okay these are these are game objects
and so prefabs are game objects so we
can just put any of these into this
field here this element zero field or
however many fields we have and it'll in
the code randomly choose one of those
and then instantiate it so any questions
as to how prefabs work or instantiation
or anything like that
okay beep does each PFF have a unique
number not a unique number they they
just are all assets in your folder here
they have some kind of identifier to
unity that's hidden from you it might be
visible from you if you look they might
have some sort of generated ID or
something like that that it so that it
knows underneath the scenes but it's not
something that you worry about in your
actual code you just tell like we've
created a list here that's just it'll
expect some number it doesn't know how
many and then in the editor you can
actually tell it how many via the
because every list that you assign to
that you create make visible in the
editor will have this size field and
that's just that's just part of the
editors abstraction the editor has
abstractions for a lot of different
objects you can create a lot of
different objects in your mono behaviors
and make them public and unity will have
a different view for them things like
color pickers and stuff like that like
you if you actually I don't know the
exact object offhand but if you make a
public color picker in your
monobehaviour or something like that
it'll actually you'll actually get a
color picker here that you can choose a
color for which is pretty awesome and
there's a lot of different like
customized views like all of these like
the I think I'm actually the directional
light might be an example see this color
here like this in in is somewhere in
code like there's a public color
something and then in the editor when
you're actually editing it you can
choose the color and unity gives you the
option to like make it whatever you want
and it's actually affecting the
background there so this is a like one
of the really big strengths of unity and
a reason to really make your components
customizable is this sort of one-to-one
mapping between your data your code and
your editor view of the code of the data
take the burden away from you
programming it which you're more prone
to make mistakes to and also waste a lot
of time and then just be able to Mont
like modify like how much faster is for
me to just say I want this red color
rather than like color dot are
equals something and then color dot G
equals something color dot B equals
something and then assign it that way
so I mean that's just a simple example
to illustrate it but there's a lot of
there's a tremendous amount of potential
involved in making your components
customizable and so that's what I did
here because I wanted the airplane
spawner or the specifically the
skyscraper spawner to spawn one of not
just one skyscraper but several
skyscrapers I created this public
prefabs list that I can then populate
from unity here and say okay this this
object this object and this object put
that into the skyscraper spawner here
these slots and then my code knows to
instantiate it randomly picking one of
those
how would you go about making something
scrollable now that you've oh yeah so I
have a a scrollable script here so it's
the Oh No oh you mean do you mean the
infinite scrolling background or the
scrollable object oh yeah yeah so in
order to do that so we've made the
scrollable script here so you would just
go to in this case since we're
instantiating all of the coins and
skyscrapers and airplanes as prefabs you
actually edit the prefab itself so I'd
go to this coin prefab I'd add component
here at the bottom and I will just add
scrollable there which is a script and
you can tell it's yours because it says
script they're just like coin here is a
script and rotate script of the script
that's actually an old script that I
don't didn't use anymore because in the
coin I just made it part of the coin
itself but this is another part of what
makes the coin class by the way is this
transform dot rotate x y&z in worlds in
the different space either relative to
itself or to the world space in this
case it shows the world space because I
want it to rotate on the worlds y axis
but if you rotate an object its own XYZ
our stike still exists and so you can
have something rotate about its own x
y&z regardless of its rotation in the
world and so I want the coin to always
rotate so 5 degrees on the y axis here
so another this is another part that you
could take and make it its own script
just a rotatable script auto rotate
script and then just make these public
fields like public X public wide public
Z and then you could change those in the
editor and then like actually make your
different objects customize your objects
without having to go into the code
itself
yeah
you don't have to do any of the
collision yourself because unity comes
with a 3d physics engine the actual I
mean you have to tell it what to do when
the collisions happen but you don't have
to actually code you know the you don't
have to do the 3d physics engine
yourself which is a tremendous amount of
work one of the big selling points
definitely for doing any three things in
unity I mean a lot of engines now have
3d engines for free I mean there was a
time when it was less prevalent because
there's a Collider that it gets so in
the we're looking at the where is it
again isn't like the skyscraper for
example so every skyscraper when it
collides with something in this
ontriggerenter gets passed in this
collider other and so that's gonna be
the object that that you collided with
and so you can you can get an object you
can assign a name to an object and then
get its name as well in code if you if
you need it to do that and you can also
just get in this case we wanted to know
whether it's the helicopter or not so we
got the heli controller from it but in
our game it's kind of a special case
because there's only one type of object
that has a Collider that's a non trigger
and that's the helicopter so we can
assume that this exists when we do get a
collision but otherwise we'd probably
want to say get component of heli
controller and then test it for equal to
null and if it's equal to null then we
want to like not do something because
then that'll cause us to if we tried to
call explode on a null object that's
gonna be a null pointer exception and
then you're gonna crash a game so but in
this case we're guaranteed for that not
to happen because like I said the only
Collider that can collide with this
that's not a trigger is the helicopter
object so that makes sense
oh yeah yeah that's uh all too real in
this case though all explode is is
thankfully just destroy game object and
then start a particle effect so any more
questions as to how like instantiation
prefabs using the unity editor
interacting with your model behaviors
public variables yeah
you cannot define so the question is can
do you first create the data in the
editor and then the code and then tie
them together that way you'll in order
to get a new component you will have to
create the class first the the
monobehaviour that you want and give it
the public fields that it needs for the
editor to actually read so the editor
reads your script looks through all the
public fields and then will create the
necessary GUI elements in the editor to
interact with the code but you this
needs to exist all this code needs to
exist anything that has these public
variables that you want accessible in
the editor needs to exist in code first
and then you have the power to use it in
the editor and then it's you know
customizable at that point any more
questions all right so that's the
prefabs so we looked at texture
scrolling before and we're gonna go kind
of quickly through this but all texture
scrolling was if we recall was I have a
scrolling background class here it's got
a scroll speed so if we wanted to we
could since it's public we can edit it
in the editor and make it faster or
slower but it we tape maintain a
reference to our renderer every object
has a renderer mesh renderer typically
for 3d objects and the renderer has a
material associated with it everything
in unity has a material and so every
material material doesn't necessarily
have a texture but in this case our
background does have a texture and it's
gonna be called main text by default
that's like the main sort of texture if
we want to assign a texture to see
visually on a material so material can
just be a color often but it can also be
a color and also a texture so in this
case the background is a texture it does
have a texture assigned to it and notice
that if we go to the background and then
here is where we actually create so it's
a this is a material here it's got a
shader so we're not going to talk too
much about what shaders are we've talked
about them briefly and unity they're
quite a bit more you can go quite a bit
farther with them well technically
speaking I guess you could go equally
far with love 2d 2d shaders and 3d
shaders
at least in vertex and fragment shaders
but the for all intents and purposes
we're not going to go into detail on
shaders today but they're very similar
in this case every every material has a
shader in unity in order for it to
render because anything that renders
needs to be shaded in unity but notice
that here we have a texture so this is
that main texture thing that we saw
before and then this is the bump map
here we don't have a bump map because
our texture isn't bumpy it doesn't have
any like contour like detail or anything
like that but you can just select a
texture here so I could give it that
texture if I wanted to or like I have
another couple textures here this
texture here it doesn't matter which
texture you choose but you can choose a
texture and then that material will then
it'll calculate based on the mesh how to
draw that texture best to it and you can
set every materials texture offset via a
texture offset function on the X and the
y-axis and that will shift it just like
we did just like basically effectively
accomplishing what a scrolling
background needs it'll draw it and then
it'll basically wrap around to the other
side so that's how we get the infinite
scrolling texture we just set its
texture offset we specifically call set
extra offset on the main texture and
then we pass in a vector too so just to
members offset and zero because we don't
want touch the y-axis so zero and then
offset is just some value that increases
over time and then time dot time recall
time since the beginning of the game has
started time dot Delta time time since
the last frame and so we can just do a
one calculation in here and update every
time and then multiply it times scroll
speed to get the scroll amount that we
want here and I've set it to 0.1 just
for a kind of a semi slow effect but in
the editor if we look at our scrolling
background which is here and then I've
made it public so I could just easily
make this like one and I don't know how
fast that's gonna be but ten times
faster so probably pretty fast
yep so it's hauling butt yeah all it is
is just shifting how with how it render
how it maps the texture on to the 3d
surface and this 3d surface to be clear
is just a plane so just a plane and
notice that it doesn't get rendered from
the back so anything that's just one
side of which is a polygon has a one
side that gets shaded and one side that
does not get shaded so if you see
invisibility on one side and not
invisibility on one side that's not a
that's not a bug that's a feature that's
the texture scrolling side of things
anybody have any questions as to how
sort of that works we won't really need
it for much going forward it's not part
of the assignment but it's ties in to
what we've done before so that would be
interesting to cover last thing we'll
look at is audio audio is pretty easy
all you need in unity to do audio is an
audio source and an audio listener so a
source plays audio so like if if James
if you if you were an audio source I'd
be an audio listener and I'm listening
for audio and playing it back to the
speakers when I get a when I hear any
sort of source of audio in the game
world so you can have infinite audio
sources but ideally one audio listener
and it's usually whatever main camera
that you're that you're drawing with and
then sounds in unity can be either 2d or
3d in this case all the sounds that I've
put into this game are 2d and that's
just the spatial blend here notice that
there's a 2d to 3d sort of slide and so
that will calculate based on where the
sound is how it sounds in the game space
and it based on how far away it is and
like what side of you it is and so the
main camera has the audio source for the
music and so it just starts the music
right away so play on notice that we
didn't have to code any of this I just
attached an audio source to the camera
and then there's a play on awake
checkbox and a loop checkbox so normally
we've done like at the start of our game
code it's set looping to true and then
play the source in this case we'd have
to do none of those things this is just
given to us by unity by default
yep you can put it on anything you want
to sound is rolled into that object yeah
and that's I mean that's audio it's
pretty simple
maybe I mean it's an art form when it
comes to how you want to position things
in your game world and how you want them
to sound and whatnot and you can get
more complicated with it but that's how
you would do basic 2d in this case audio
but you could easily also do 3d audio
just by making this set to 0 from 0 to 1
and you can make it more or less 3d to
like if it's not all the way to 1
it'll somewhat be 2d so you'll so you'll
hear some of it no matter what and some
of it will be 3d and then sitting it to
one it'll be purely 3d so I think it's
far enough away you won't hear it at all
the explosion sound as well gets
triggered and so this happens in the I
forget exactly offhand where it gets
triggered so it's in the leave it's in
the helicopter explode function oh yes I
created an object with the explosion
with I created an object in the scene
that has an audio source for the
explosion sound and because I made this
public I can just put it on this object
and so there's a reference set audio
source at all times and so I trigger
explosion sound op play whenever we call
this explode method on the heli
controller for the reason that I didn't
put it on this object because we destroy
this object as soon as we get into a
collision and so I didn't want to put
the sort of explosion sound audio source
on this object it would get destroyed in
there it would not play audio
effectively as soon as we destroy it so
we have to have it somewhere else on the
scene I could have also just like like
made the object invisible but I didn't I
destroyed it and so yeah that was the
that's this explosion sound object which
if we look at the helicopter in the heli
controller which is all the way down
here notice that it gets in a explosion
particles as a reference to an explosion
particle system and an explosion sound
and we just have to click and drag the
object effectively from here to here to
pair the two of them and then the script
that this is referring to will always
have a reference to those as long as
these are set to something and then so
we also have coin total we made public
so I guess I could experiment with it
and then speed we made this public so
that you can make the helicopter faster
if you want it to or slower and so
you'll find it often useful to make a
lot of these fields public just for you
to experiment with and then there's no
really harm in doing so because folks
aren't gonna be able to actually see
this in the editor when they download
your game so make as much public as you
want for debugging purposes and just
have fun with it but that's audio audio
sources produce the sound audio
listeners listen to the sound and
actually make it go through your
computer speakers or whatever your
default audio Optim is and here's just a
showcase of the two on the camera and
that's that's audio so any questions as
to like how the audio works at all
all right a couple last things before we
close out here so the asset store is
probably one of the biggest things about
unity that kind of sells it so
oftentimes it's a lot easier just to get
something you know whether it's a
library if you're programming or
something else get something that's
implemented for you so that you don't
have to implement it yourself
in this case there's an RPG systems for
rapid development something visual
scripting system sort of similar to
unreal there's a ton of things in the
asset store models
object scripts audio editor toolkits a
lot of cool logical things a lot of its
free if you want experiment so like a
lot of the assets that I got to mess
with in this game here are free like the
coin and some of the other stuff that's
bundled with it
there's a lot of really cool things and
really cool systems to help you for like
10 or 20 bucks you can spend a little
bit of money and then get like 25% of
your game done like right away and then
you can actually get closer to shipping
it so it's I think it's hugely valuable
to be looking at the asset store and
thinking about how you can save your
time that way if you're trying to
actually ship a game and get to market
so definitely look through the asset
store see if there's anything that will
make your life easier when it comes to
developing games because I know that
I've used it several times and I rarely
regret doing so so assignment 8 is going
to be pretty simple so we looked at for
the second part you know there's a bug
in the game where if you die over and
over again the scroll speed never resets
so we'll just keep being faster and
faster and faster and faster forever but
it's a one-line fix and I want you guys
to find where to fix it given that we
know given what we've seen today and
there's a hint here about static
variables so I'll also be detailed in
the spec as well but this is an easy
part this part is fairly easy too
because all it really is is taking the
kind of the same stuff we've looked at
the coin generator and coins and then
making gems that spawn instead are not
instead but in addition to the coins at
a rarer rate and these gems should be
worth 5 coins and so when you collide
with the gems just add five to the coin
total if you collide with a coin add one
to the coin total and that's basically
it for assignment eight so next time
we're gonna dive into first-person games
in unity so we'll look at some of the
features that we get for free we're
gonna implement kind of a simple maze
like game where you can navigate and
it'll be dark and kind of scary similar
to a game called dread halls which is a
mobile VR game and we'll actually test
out unities VR and try and get a VR
headset in here so people can check that
out
cool thanks a lot I'll see you guys next
time